this is sigale a neighborhood in
mogadishu
where people are leaving their homes
trouble started on sunday when
pro-government and opposition security
forces
clashed during protests against the
extension of president muhammad
abdullahi for major stamina office by
another two years
it had expired in february but talks to
hold a new election
ha fails somalis who are getting out
say they're wary and want these problems
to end
we are fleeing because of the war we are
leaving behind our houses
we've not slept for two days because of
the clashes please stop fighting so we
can return home
opposition forces including some
soldiers who left front line positions
in hershey ballet
in the south of the country have taken
control of several neighborhoods
erecting barricades with stones and
mounds of soil as well as digging
trenches
the government says it's fighting armed
groups brought to the city by opposition
political leaders to cause chaos
those organizing these actions know how
shabab and isis may hide among their
force
we have information that armed men are
going into people's houses to harass
them
we do not want to use force and cause
confrontation
the government will however take the
responsibility of protecting citizens
diplomats and clan elders are said to be
trying to broker talks
between the warring groups to
de-escalate tensions
some analysts say the president is
running out of options
the best option so far is for him to go
back to the negotiating table within the
framework of 17th of september agreement
that's what every member of the
international community is calling for
right now and most somalis are also
calling for that
um certainly if he does not do that
the the alternative is to continue with
the confrontation
um which will certainly lead to conflict
and further
bloodshed and no one can win a a
an urban warfare i mean mogadishu has
experienced three major urban warfares
these are dangerous times in a fragile
country somalia is dealing with threats
from the armed group al-shabab
drought and a struggling economy and
people are now even more worried
about what they see as the
politicization of the military and
police force
which appears to be increasingly
fragmented along political lines
catherine soy al jazeera